when.
We will begin the public hearing in just a couple minutes.
If you are not speaking but wish to indicate how you feel about the bill, either pro or con, please sign the blue sheet over on the table on the side wall over there.
It would be appreciated.
We'll begin the public hearing in just a couple minutes.
Thank you.
I'm about to open the public hearing on House Bill 2022, an act relative to the 10-year transportation plan, and I would call on Representative Pat Abramny.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
For the record, State Rep.
Pat Abramny, Rocky M19 Stratum.
I'm here to request, at the request of the Stratum Select Board, to discuss the NH 108 Bunker Hill Avenue traffic light request, which is in the plan.
And it's been in the plan.
It was a Rockingham Planning Commission priority project for 2019 to 2028.
If we could turn to page 170 of the proposed plan, you'll see that listed there.
Thank you.
On page 170 of the proposed plan, you'll see that listed there.
But this has been a priority for stratum for at least 15 years before it made it to the 10-year plan in 2019.
Just in the past 10 years, there have been 35 collisions at that intersection.
On page 171, right across from this, you'll see the Stratum Greenland project implement safety improvements along New Hampshire 33 corridor.
Our select board is happy to see this project added and given immediate status.
However, they feel that the traffic light project is of higher priority for the town of Stratum.
My counsel to the select board was asking for more money in the plan to move the traffic light project forward more quickly would be a non-starter in this committee.
However, getting an agreement with Greenland to slow the Route 33 project to be able to move the traffic light project forward would be the only way to amend the 10-year plan.
If executing this plan next week instead of today, if that happens, or if there is a negotiation between Stratum and Greenland that concludes with an agreement, there is a chance an amendment would come forward.
Given the calendar, an amendment more likely would be done in the Senate, although this committee would have to concur with any change that's done in the Senate.
Our Stratum Town planner, Mark Connors, will be testifying in a bit to add some additional context to this.
So those are my only comments, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you.
Questions to Representative Romney from members of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you.
For the members of the public who are waiting here to testify, the tradition of the House and Senate both is to take the representatives who have to go off to other committees and do their work first, and then hear from members of the general public or those representing towns or counties.
Moving on, Representative Ulery.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
For the record, my name is Jordan Ollery, representing Hillsboro 37, Hudson, and Pelham.
Somehow or another, the Hudson Circumferential Highway, which has always been part of the plan for decades and has partially been built with the Sagamore Bridge, was not on the plan this year.
I don't know how that happened, particularly since the governor said that he wanted it in there.
However, before you've got several packages of support from a variety of people, state senators, our two U.S.
senators, and the National Regional Planning Commission.
Lowell Road in Hudson is a failed road.
It's a state road.
It's failed.
Right now, to get from the Sagamore Bridge to Presentation in Mary, where the road goes from four to two lanes either direction takes during the rush hour 30 to 45 minutes.
The distance is less than a mile.
Traffic is heavy.
The majority of the traffic is not Hudson residents.
The majority of the traffic are Litchfield, Wyndham, Salem, and Londonderry.
This is not a Hudson town situation as far as service.
This is a regional problem.
because people take Wall Road to get to the Sagamore Bridge to get to Route 3 to get to the I suppose the Western take Wall Road to get to the Sagamore Bridge to get to Route 3, to get to the, I suppose, the western or southern side of 128 to Waltham to the high-tech businesses down there to avoid traveling 128 from 93 up, which is also a failed road, but that's Massachusetts' problem, not ours.
In order to make Hudson a safer road, to make the travel for all who use that road safer, the first arc needs to be done.
That is the arc from Route 3 at the end of the Sagamore Park Road to 111 needs to be done.
Mitigation for that, even though there are some wetlands in there, mitigation has already been planned for.
The state owns a big chunk of the road.
In discussion with the DOT commissioner, what needs to be done first is a feasibility study.
We're asking for an immediate status of $1 million to get a feasibility study done so that we can find out once and for all what's going on.
Hudson is unique in that it has good access to the turnpike system, and it has land on which buildings can be built.
It has an industrial park which has a 50 foot height limit which allows for high rise buildings to be built.
We've already got one in the planning stage.
It's being discussed in the courts of course by the neighbors.
and another one that's coming up that's being discussed, which I don't know what will happen with that.
I can't say because I'm on the planning board.
I do know that Hudson planned ahead for the Sagamore Bridge by taking land from the new development, whether it's a small development with a Starbucks and a bank and a couple other Jersey Mikes, first Jersey Mike's in New Hampshire, good subs.
We mandated that they give an additional turn lane.
When we're ready to take it, DOT is already ready to take it.
So that's already with no additional cost to the state.
As part of the planning board decision and development stipulations.
They have a turning lane that's coming in there, so there will be two turning lanes southbound off of Route 3A.
This is an urgent situation.
Accidents increase.
Traffic is increasing.
The quality of life for not only Hudson residents, but the towns previously mentioned are being affected.
Jobs are coming into Hudson because we have a thriving business program, and we have space for businesses to develop and grow.
We need the feasibility study done so that we can come back and say this is what's needed for this and this is what the study says can or cannot be done.
So, therefore, I believe that this plan is remiss in not including $1 million for the feasibility study.
I will read from a September 9, 2020 letter from the governor to the chairman of the board of selectmen, whose president was Mr.
David Morin.
Just one short paragraph, and I have the whole thing here.
I just lost it.
It is important to note that given our current sustained economic condition, the time frame in which project funding is available is limited and requires immediate approval by the town.
Well, the town's ready to go forward now.
It has been for a long time.
There's been some internal squabbling.
There always are.
You all are familiar with your own town governments.
You know what that's like.
The governor wants this as a priority.
How it didn't get put on the plan?
Well, things get missed.
I'm not here to give blame.
We all have some idea where things happen.
But this $1 million for a feasibility study is essential so that we can get started or know what to do with it.
I will also say that there are some group of individuals, a smaller group in town, that want to take the entire state property without going through due process and make it into a park.
A good chunk of that land is already owned.
This feasibility study would be the key to improving the traffic flow within the next several years.
It would be the key to helping the communities previously listed, Hudson, Wyndham, Salem to a degree, Londonderry, and Litchfield.
We have to get this done.
We need that extra million dollars.
I'll be happy to answer any questions that you may have.
Thank you.
Representative Eaton.
Just a quick one, Representative Eaton.
Any money we move in this has to be counterbalanced by something else.
The $1 million figure you have, is that something that was just pulled out of let's have a million bucks to do a study, or is it based on someone giving you an estimate of what the study would cost so we're not grabbing money out that could be used otherwise?
Thank you.
It's good to see.
I haven't seen you in a while.
Oh.
Well, I've already had one.
No, that's a number that is given to us by the commissioner in DOT.
Any other questions?
Seeing none, thank you.
Oh, wait a minute.
Representative Thompson.
Good morning, Representative.
Oh, wait a minute.
Representative Thompson.
Good morning, Representative.
Thank you for your testimony.
I noticed in these letters of recommendation there's a number of comments about the BUILD grant.
What will that BUILD grant cover, and will it not cover this million-dollar feasibility study?
That was from the 2018 bill grant application.
That doesn't necessarily apply currently.
It was included merely to show that we have support across various towns.
I would pay more attention to the NRPC, National Regional Planning Commission, and the letters from the governors as well as the two senators, sir, the two U.S.
senators.
The bill grant would include building the entire circumferential highway, which would go around Hudson from just in broad terms and without wiggles and waggles and all the stuff that's needed would go from 3A at the Sagamore Bridge right off of the turnpike over to 111.
Then from 111 to 102.
And then from 102 back to 3A in Litchfield.
And if you go back to the original plan, it would connect with the Henry Burke Highway in Nashua.
It's my understanding from the town engineer that the biggest objection to the plan to begin with was so many bridges in such close proximity from the Army Corps of Engineers.
So I don't think that the bridge at the end of the Henry Burke Highway over the Merrimack River will be completed because a large chunk of that traffic has been taken care of by the Pearl Harbor Survivors Bridge up in Londonderry.
So let's not worry about that.
But we do need to get traffic out of the center of Hudson, which is three centuries old, coming up on it, for the roads going through it are, for the most part, going through the center of town unimproved in any way, shape, or form It's an improved four lane road, low road, but the traffic capacity has exceeded that.
Of course, you know, I know traffic grows to fill the void, but if we can divert the traffic from the center of town, we take the load off of state roads that need to be maintained all the time by pushing it off onto other roads so there's a smaller flow of traffic of cars heading out towards the east of Hudson.
And that will take a big chunk of the traffic out of the center of town and the traffic hazards that are associated there.
If you take a look at the Hudson Police accident reports, there's a large number of them that have taken place, some going south towards Kingsborough, some off Wasson Road.
It's another story.
But they're taking Wasson Road to avoid the center of town, and as a result, you have people that are trying to make up time on a back road literal cow path, actually probably a deer path of a paved road.
So this becomes vital for the vitality of the entire southern region.
Okay.
A quick follow up Mr.
Chairman.
A quick follow up, yes.
Thank you.
of the entire southern region.
Okay.
A quick follow-up, Mr.
Chairman.
A quick follow-up, yes.
It indicates here that there's 4.5 miles of property that is going to need to be taken one way or another.
What portion of that does the town already own?
Well, the town doesn't own most of the property.
The state already owns most of the property.
They do.
They already took most of that property, except for the small section the town took back without telling the state.
Thank you very much.
Representative Newman.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking the question.
Over the last several months, when I do travel to Hudson from North Nashua and go down Lowell Road, I've noticed, I think there are five buildings.
Are those apartments or condos?
And do you know how many there actually are?
And if there's going to be some traffic impact.
Actually, I'm on the planning board in Hudson as well.
Dakota Properties put up some affordable housing right there at the top of the road, just opposite the wetlands that belong to Presentation of Mary Academy.
That building is complete.
They're awaiting the installation of some appliances before they open it up for residency in the very near future.
I don't, CO hasn't been issued yet, has it?
All right, so the first building certificate of occupancy has been built, according to the town engineer.
And I don't remember right off the top of my head.
The way we designed the traffic on that, however, was for southbound in, southbound out, northbound, you're going to have to go through the industrial park, come up to a traffic light and make a left-hand turn if you want to go northbound.
So we pushed the traffic away from the bottleneck area down southerly where there's several traffic lights which people can indicate, which is also the plan for the proposed 500,000 square foot warehouse right behind that building are those buildings there's two buildings 481 apartments thank you Seeing no further questions, thank you.
Representative Rice.
Two minutes.
I am always very brief and to the point.
Representative Olery stated much of what I was going to say, but for the record, I'm Representative Kim Rice.
I represent Hillsborough 37 Hudson and Pelham, and I happen to be a Hudson resident, and I wish I could be here today as a resident to express to you the faulty traffic we have in town.
It takes me forever forever to get home I won't leave my house after a certain time after four o'clock if I'm home I don't leave because I'm not sitting in that traffic I'm not we have the wonderful suicide lane which is a nightmare in itself but I do want to you know did want to express what representative Olery said we have you know two big projects coming to town that's bringing a lot of jobs for people, and this really needs to be addressed.
The residents really need some relief from this traffic.
And that's basically all I have to say.
Representative Olery covered everything.
Thanks.
Questions from members of the committee?
I do have one, and maybe the department might be able to answer it later when we hear from them.
But as you know, this whole 10-year plan is a zero-sum game.
If we take a million dollars to do this feasibility study, do you have any suggestions on which town gives up their project?
No.
I don't.
Sorry.
But, you know, I do want to express the importance of this job being done and, you know, the really negative impact it's having on the lives of the residents of Hudson because we do cater to the traffic from Massachusetts, from Pelham, from Londonderry, Windham, Nashua are all cutting through the town, and I'm at my wit's end.
So I can just imagine everyone else in town.
So thank you for considering it, and I really, really hope that this gets approved.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Seeing none, thank you very much, Representative Rice.
Moving on to a different subject.
Representative The Burge.
Thank you.
If you could hold up for a minute.
Representative Rulery, I was asked to remind you that you're at exec session across the hall.
Okay, Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee, I'm going to not take much of your time because there's somebody that's following me, the Coast County Commissioner, that will give you all the details, and I don't want to reiterate that.
But I do want to thank you for your time and patience and indulgence regarding the request being made to allow funds for the Gulf Links Road in Dixville and Colbrook, which is currently owned by the state-owned.
However, in summary, what I would like to say is that one way to reinstate the funds for the above would be to convince a municipality, as you well know, to give up a project and redirect funds for the Balsam's initiative.
Personally, it would be suicidal for any municipality and clearly unethical on my part to request such action to be taken.
However, what is possible is to advocate for the use of funds given to the state via the American Rescue Plan Act.
However, this morning I received an email.
I was asking for detailed information regarding the ARP funds from the governor's office, and the commissioner, who will follow me later on regarding this road project, will clarify that.
That being said, the act does allow under economic adjustment assistance programs to help hundreds of communities nationwide to plan, build, innovate and put people back to work through the construction design and to meet local needs.
The Gulf Links Road project qualifies for such an assistance.
However, more clarification on the use of those funds need to come forth.
Nonetheless, the conditions should be placed for the above funding if it were to be implemented.
Thank you.
on the use of those funds need to come forth.
Nonetheless, the condition should be placed for the above funding if it were to be implemented.
That is, that none of the funds can be used until such times that all financial agreements are in place and in conjunction with the first shovel of dirt being turned.
Thank you.
I noticed that you were reading.
If you could give that to the clerk for the files, it would be useful in any future discussions we may have about this.
Are there any questions of Representative LeBurge from members of the committee.
Seeing none, thank you.
I next call Mr.
Ray Gorman, Coas County Chamber.
It doesn't say that, but okay.
mistake oh the red lights on now we're in business okay well thank you very much for letting me speak in front of you as well as cross County Commissioner I am Colbrook selectman a four-term selectman and I I was a longtime I worked at the balsams for 32 years until it closed.
Golf links road is a very important part of the development of the balsams it's about two miles long and it is the road that goes from the hotel to the country club it's two miles if you You go up about a third of the way, and you have Two Town Ponds, and Two Town Ponds is called that name because it's half in Cobrick and half in Dixville.
The rest of the way up, you're on Golf Links Road.
You're in Cobrick, leading to the golf course.
It's a Donald Ross signature golf course.
It was always very busy when we were open.
And the potential for development along this road is significant, but it's even far more significant to the golf course that it leads to, okay, the 18-hole golf course, and has been maintained even though the hotel has been closed.
All of the golf course is in the town of Coburg, and they pay taxes to the town of Coburg.
With the significant development that will occur around the golf course, it will have a significant impact on especially the community of Coburg.
Our part of Golf Links Road, we've already worked with the developer on, And got right away things that we we have done legally to set them up to do what they need to do their developments for building homes it could be tens of millions of dollars if things go as planned with mr.
and it could be in the next three 36 months he's talking about $35 million worth of homes.
They are developing the plans.
They have three different protocol homes that they have set up.
And the impact that would have on our tax base in Colbic would be significant.
This road we have been talking about with DOT for several years.
I believe it was about five to six years ago, we had a meeting at the Balsams.
Ms.
Sheehan was there.
Executive Council was there as well.
Biela Montang.
We met with and had a long conversation about two projects.
We have our Main Street project in Colbrook at that time, which is in two parts.
And one part has already been completed, and the other part we hope to complete in 2023.
And we have a meeting with DOT tomorrow morning for some of the finalization of that.
And it's gone very well, and our work with DOT has gone very well.
So Golf Links Road is important, very important to our plans.
Now, especially where Mr.
Otten has presented, he has a Sasha and Gold, he has protected a non-profit by the name of Provident.
He has come to the county with significant plans and with financial backing.
We, the county, are completely supporting that with $30 million worth of bonds.
Our attorneys are working together.
We had a commissioner's meeting yesterday, and everything seems to be moving along smoothly.
So the county is doing its part to commit to the development there and what it will bring to the county and the surrounding communities like Colbrook.
Golf Links Road is a key and that's it's really important and we will do anything we can to the meeting so on and so forth.
I believe it was on the 10-year plan the town of Colbrook was never informed that there was that it was being taken off from the 10-year plan.
The town of Colbrook was never informed that it was being taken off from the 10-year plan.
One of our selectmen the other day when we were talking about this said it's been taken off.
I said, yes, it has.
And so we're looking to get back the funding for this.
the economic development it can do for the North Country, for Colbrook, and for the whole county is significant.
We need to be back on that plan.
The road is owned by the state.
I mean, in all my years there, the state did what it needed to do as far as patching things for us to use it in the summer.
It would be closed in the winter and we'd use it as a cross-country ski course.
And this road, as you go up it, it goes off to Nathan Pond and Mud Pond, which is an area that has significant use by snowmobilers, OHRV, hunting and fishing.
It's an area that can easily be developed.
I haven't seen any plans for that but there will be plans it accesses the main hotel to the golf course panorama golf course in all those areas which are in Colbrook which really are significant for us anything we can do to move this along we need your I'm just going to make a quick statement about my community of Colbert.
Our upcoming town meeting, we have Article Number 2 is for 3.
million for improvements in our sewer.
We'll be borrowing about a million dollars.
We've got significant help with things there.
We have a water system that we're improving.
That's about a million dollars.
We'll be borrowing about $400,000.
Our community is working hard to set ourselves up to take care of the development of the balsams, which it looks like it's going to be happening.
We're definitely optimistic.
And we have another industry, APP, that's in our community.
And we're really, our community, when we brought the bond issue for our main street, passed by 90%.
We have significant local support here.
Our people want to see Colbrook move ahead.
We've taken some significant blows through the years with the loss of Ethan Allen jobs, with the loss of the paper mill in Grovedon, and we've just, and the balsams, we have taken significant losses.
And I can tell you, once the balsams closed personally three jobs to stay in the community.
All right.
And we've got a lot of good, hard-working people there.
The hotel had an incredible reputation.
The Rubber Factory and those folks were good, hard workers.
And we need to look to you folks for some help with this Golf Links Road to get it developed because it's going to be a huge asset to the development of that Panorama of Donald Ross course into the whole development there.
And I believe this can happen, and I believe you folks will help us support this.
Thank you.
Any questions from members of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you.
Mr.
Mark Connors from the town of Stratham.
Good morning.
Chairman Graham, Vice Chairman McConkie, all members of the committee, thank you for having me today.
I'm here to speak on Project 41711.
The town of Stratum is respectfully requesting that project be accelerated in the plan, and we're willing to request a separate project in Stratum, money be taken from that project to support this project project number four one seven one one is intersection improvements to bunker hill avenue and route 108 portsmouth avenue in stratum it is currently scheduled for construction in 2027 but the town would respectfully request it be moved to 2024 it's it's the town's position that this is the most important transportation safety need in our town it's been including the 10-year plan for five years after a community wide effort to have it included in the plan it's been discussed in town for decades that's why it is somewhat discouraging to the town that a different more expensive project was added to the 10-year plan by the New Hampshire Department of Transportation last year that is scheduled for construction four years earlier than the Bunker Hill Avenue intersection improvements.
That project, project number 4-3-2-7-2, would include safety improvements to the Route 33 corridor in both Stratum and Greenland.
We support safety improvements to Route 33.
However, we firmly believe that the Bunker Hill Avenue intersection improvements represent a more pressing need in our community.
The data is clear that the intersection is dangerous.
The police department has responded to 35 collisions there over the last 10 years, including seven accidents with injuries that required ambulance response.
There are poor sight lines at the intersection, and many residents, particularly older residents, tell us they avoid the intersection altogether.
In the fall of last year, we surveyed residents regarding the greatest transportation needs in Stratum, and we didn't even ask about the Route 33 project because it was so new to the plan it wasn't included in the 10-year plan at that time.
We would have asked about it, but it's come so quickly we didn't.
The project we did ask about, the Bunker Hill Avenue intersection improvements emerged as the biggest need among residents.
One resident noted this project has been kicked down the can for over 50 years and needs to be resolved.
Traffic density isn't going to decrease.
Another noted, I fear someone will eventually be killed there and then we'll ask ourselves why we didn't do something sooner.
Many residents don't simply avoid the intersection altogether.
It can take like a three-mile route to avoid the intersection and get to a signalized intersection down where Route 101 comes in in stratum.
A lot of people tell us that they do that.
In our view, this is a project where there's a rare kind of consensus among town government and the residents of Stratum that this is our biggest transportation need.
We support a corridor study of the Route 33 corridor.
We also understand the Town of Greenland is supportive of that.
The 10-year plan does include an engineering study, $125,000 engineering study that's slated for 2024, which to us that makes even less sense because why are you undertaking an engineering study before you're planning a major construction project?
The major construction project is slated for 2023.
The engineering study of the corridor is slated after that project is already started for construction.
So as I mentioned, the town of Stratum would be supportive of reallogating approximately $14.4 million projected cost of the Bunker Hill intersection improvements from the Route 33 project so that Bunker Hill intersection improvements could be completed in 2024 or sooner.
As I mentioned, we do not doubt the safety improvements are in order for the 233 corridor and we're supportive generally of that project.
However, we'd suggest that a comprehensive study of the corridor might make more sense before we schedule a major construction project there.
Thank you very much for your time today.
I'd be happy to take any questions you have.
Thank you.
Any questions from members of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you.
If you could leave your written testimony for the file, it would be appreciated by the clerk.
I have no further pink cards, but I am sure that members of the committee have some questions of the department.
From what we've heard this morning, if the commissioner and or her staff would be willing to entertain questions from the committee, I would appreciate it.
Bring as many as you would need up.
Commissioner, if we could just kind of take them in the order we heard them today.
We heard first about stratum and last about stratum and their proposal.
If you don't have an answer or comment about that at this time, we can wait till this afternoon at our executive session to talk about that proposal.
I would prefer that we defer the conversation to this afternoon because this was really the first time we'd heard about this request to change the order of the projects.
The one thing I will say is that the project that is slated to move forward in 2023 is much further along in design.
So we will take a look at the timing and the readiness of both projects and bring that information back to the committee this afternoon.
I would appreciate that.
And so for the committee, we'll hold off on the Stratham discussion until our executive session this afternoon, and the commissioner can bring back some additional information to us.
Hudson Circumvential Highway.
And the request for a $1 million feasibility study, do you have $1 million laid around to pay for this?
So we have been looking at the available balances in each fiscal year.
I'm going to be honest with the cost increases that we're seeing in terms of commodities and just the cost of construction in general, we are very tight in 2023.
We do have a lot more flexibility in 2025, but we are taking a close look to see if there's any way to make some funding available.
Maybe we could make a smaller amount available in 23 and then complete the study in 2024.
But our caution is that, as I said, the cost of doing business right now has been increasing.
And with all the projects we have programmed, if we see additional cost escalation, that will further diminish our capacity.
More representative Jack.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Commissioner.
What color would this money have to be in it, if you know what I mean?
We do believe that the feasibility study is warranted.
The circumferential project has been talked about for many, many years.
The Hudson boulevard portion which is just the southern portion is something that has come up in several 10-year plan cycles and we were a little surprised that it wasn't elevated as a need earlier in the 10-year plan process and so we we do believe there's merit to taking a close look and determining whether or not there is an alignment that could be permitted.
Previously, this was going to be a turnpike-funded project when it was the full circumferential.
If the state is making the determination that we don't intend, at least in the next 10 years, to construct the full circumferential, if we're looking at just that southern portion, it probably would be inappropriate to use turnpike funds, which is why we'd propose using federal funds for this particular study.
Once again, you've said that you are going to be looking at availability of funds.
we have to come to some kind of resolution starting this afternoon with the 10-year plan.
If you do not have something by that point to go into an amendment to the bill, I'm not sure what the committee's pleasure will be, but if you could bring something back this afternoon to the executive session on what you think you can do, and if the answer is you can't, then be honest with us.
That's all that any of us ask.
Like I said, we could probably accommodate this easily in 2025, but doing it sooner is challenging.
That's what we're taking a close look at.
Thank you.
Members of the committee, Representative Thompson.
If you can get to it in 2025, how long is that going to take with the feasibility study and get ready to?
I guess the question, my direct question is, how soon before these people see some relief from completed construction?
Just a guess.
So it is unclear whether or not we could secure the environmental permits to build the project on the alignment that was originally proposed for the circumferential highway.
The reason the circumferential did not move forward was because EPA could not support the project as proposed.
So this feasibility study would look at, you know, if we're only building a two-lane roadway at this boulevard instead of a four-lane turnpike what would the impacts be and how would we mitigate those impacts as well as look at potential alternative alignments that might be more palatable so that work would probably take a good 12 to 18 months if you include the time to secure a consultant to help us with that work and then of course we don't know what the would be.
Depending on the alternative and the feasibility, we'd have to advance the design of that solution.
Order of magnitude-wise, when the town was pursuing the bill grant, which was just to construct the southern portion of the circumferential, just the Hudson Boulevard that we're describing, it was around $40 to $50 million was the estimate for for that construction cost so we'd have to secure those dollars in a future 10-year plan cycle to fund the project as well so looking at five to eight years i'm sorry an additional five to eight years probably um before you get get to the completion of construction.
Okay.
Thank you.
Representative Ebel.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Commissioner, for being here.
I was curious whether this project was ranked as a very high priority by the RPC that represents Hudson through their TAP process.
So this project was not submitted as a candidate for any of the programs like TAP or CMAC and it did not get submitted as a candidate for consideration when the Regional Planning Commission did their call for projects.
Follow-up.
So in preparing the initial draft of the 10-year plan for review by Gasset, the Governor didn't include this project in the draft.
Is that the way the, do I understand the process correctly?
In the draft plan that the Department prepared back in the summertime, we did not include it because it had not been identified as a Regional Planning Commission priority.
When this project was in the 10-year plan previously, it was intended to be funded by the state the request that we had received from the town of hudson was to partner with them they intended to pursue the bill grant application and should they be successful and have secured those dollars the department was then authorized to work with the town because we own the property.
We would have been able to review the submissions as their design consultant advanced the project, but there was no federal turnpike or state funding allocated to the project when it was previously in the 10-year plan.
So moving forward, they didn't secure the grant, so we did not include it in the initial draft of the 10-year plan.
The councillors did not include this project either, and you're correct, the governor did not add the project-year plan.
The counselors did not include this project either, and you're correct, the governor did not add the project to the plan.
Further questions on this issue?
Moving on to the next one, Gulf Links Road.
I know it was in a previous plan.
Could you identify what in that plan was the source of funding for Golf Links Road?
At that time, it was anticipated that we would fund the work with the Betterment program.
And if we were to include it now, where would the money have to come from?
So as I have described at previous work sessions, we're in a different place today when it comes to our state highway revenues, and we have seen declines, especially during the COVID pandemic period in available funding for betterment projects.
And so if there was a decision made to fund this through those traditional sources, that would be at the expense of other paving projects that we anticipate doing through the betterment funding source.
That is why we've suggested that perhaps an alternate source of funding be pursued, because we really would not want to see our capacity diminished when it comes to our overall paving program.
In order of magnitude-wise, we spend about 20 million, 20 to 22 million of betterment funding on paving.
And this project we anticipate would cost probably around $2.5 million to $3.5 million in today's dollars.
Representative Ewell.
Thank you.
I have a similar question to the question that I just asked about Hudson.
You know, there's a real process that these things follow.
It's kind of set in stone.
Where did this rank or did it rank in the recommendations of the RPC for that area?
So once again, this was not brought forward as an RPC recommendation.
However, the RPCs are typically identifying projects that would be advanced with federal funds.
We have such limited state funds that the department puts together the paving plans and determines how best to use the betterment funding.
So I'm not surprised that this wasn't identified as an RPC priority because it's not a section of roadway that's eligible for federal funds.
Thank you.
Further questions from members of the committee?
Representative Jack.
Jack.
Thank you again, Mr.
Chairman.
It's probably only right to ask us about the stratum project also.
The RPC phase, the town mentioned that there was another project they wanted to take the founts from.
They were a little surprised that it was advanced.
And if we could get the information on how that got in at the RPC phase, that might be helpful.
Excuse me.
Bill Cass, the Assistant Commissioner.
The project that was added was a result of some safety studies working with both Stratum and Greenland, and Senator Sherman was also very involved.
He had spearheaded some dialogue about concerns with access to Route 33 on that segment.
So as part of those discussions through the Highway Safety Improvement Program, in conjunction with the paving program, we looked at that section of highway and said that we could look at adding a center turning lane through that in conjunction with some upcoming resurfacing that was going on.
So one of the reasons that it is accelerated or that it got included earlier was because it is coordinated with some paving work and resurfacing of Route 33.
There needs to be some work to beef up the shoulders to allow some of the incremental widening to put a center turn lane to improve safety and improve turning movements at those corridors.
in conjunction with the paving program and the safety program, and that it doesn't have the external impacts that the Bunker Hill Road intersection does in terms of right-of-way and other potential historic and environmental impacts that need to be dealt with.
It was easier to put it in sooner rather than later.
Representative Ewell.
Thank you.
Could you just clarify whether all these concerns were raised at the Gasset level of review of the 10-year plan, and if so, I guess it would appear that the Executive Counselors elected not to add them.
So I'll go through each project.
So Hudson, we did not receive any testimony during the Gasset phase.
During one of our work sessions, you might recall that we had a list of all the projects that we specifically were drawing attention to.
So on that list, there was both the Balsams Project as well as the Hudson Boulevard.
So we did not receive any testimony in the Gasset phase for either of those projects.
But the conclusion of the Gasset phase, because there had been some developments in terms of the Balsams team securing funding to advance their project, Councillor Kenney did indicate that it might be time to revisit Golf Links Road, but that was all just emerging information at the time that we were working on the Gasset draft of the 10-year plan.
And I would say I know Stratum did come up.
We had a lot of discussion with Council of Stevens about it and the concern.
We know that it's a priority.
It is in the 10-year plan and we are committed to working on it beginning when the funding is programmed with the engineering next year.
I'll go out a little bit and say if it can be accelerated, I think that would be our goal given the concerns.
But we also know that there are other issues there more there more than just traffic because it is a historic area and there will be right-of-way impacts, and those things typically take time to work through in developing a preferred alternative and identifying those impacts.
We did in Stratum look at if there was a short-term immediate fix that we could do.
We did look at, I wouldn't address the whole issue, we did look at with some of the safety funds if a right turn lane could be added within the right of way, something that could be done more immediately.
But as we looked at that and the impacts of that, it did get slope impacts onto historic properties, which would have gone into more evaluation to evaluate it, and it wasn't feasible to do the quick implementation of the right turn lane.
And the project got programmed, and we're anxious to get started to work on it.
Any further questions on these issues that were raised by members of the legislature or the public this morning to the department?
I do have one other thing, Commissioner.
I know your staff shared with me a list of municipal bridges.
If we could pass that out at this point, or were you going to wait until bring it in this afternoon?
We had thought that it would be more appropriate to bring it this afternoon.
Okay, we'll do it then.
Any further questions of the department?
Again, thank you for your time and consideration of our our meandering questions here, Commissioner.
We appreciate it.
Is there anybody who has not testified on House Bill 2022 who wishes to testify at this time?
Is there anybody who has spoken once that wishes to speak a second time on House Bill 2022?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
For members of the committee, I once again misjudged time a little bit.
Our executive session is on this bill is at 1.15 this afternoon.
The commissioner has agreed to bring in a couple of items of information for our consideration at that time we'll also look at what we an amendment that was prepared based on artists our straw discussions last week and we'll go on from there we will see how far we get.
Probably not going to finish today.
Because we'll see because we have to deal with all of these questions and then get them put into an amendment if we accept any of the suggestions to include the one that the commissioner is going to bring in.
So we have some time.
Be back here at 1.15.
My apologies to the members of the committee about having three hours to kill.
Thank you all.
And we will be back at 1 15 Thank you.
Thank you.
Look at that.
The time being 1.15, I'd like to call the executive session on House Bill 2022 to order.
First, I would like to point out that what I passed out to the members of the committee is Amendment 0496H, which is all that we agreed to last week in our work sessions.
This will be what we build on today, whether we add or subtract from it.
And I'm stalling, waiting for the commissioner to come back because she was going to bring some other information But we do have one thing Representative McConkie has a proposed amendment that he'd like to bring up at this point And while he's passing it out, there will be dead silence.
Thank you.
Everybody but me there, Vice Chair.
I'm Senator McConkie.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thanks for the indulgence by the committee.
I have an item I would like to add to the 10-year plan that is not a project.
It does not bump anything that's in there.
it would simply be a footnote that would be added into the report.
The committee has done this previously to put something small in for future expansion or something another time.
I have a, just outside my district, I have Route 15 153 starts in Wakefield runs to Conway the selectmen from Wakefield Effingham freedom and eaton have all approached me and the traffic bureau wanting to think into the future of how to manage the increase in traffic which is tremendously tremendously higher.
Segmented by GPS, it's a parallel road to Route 16.
And with all the work that was done on Route 16 of bridges and so forth, the public was directed through 153, and they've never left.
So it's a two-lane road with minimal to no shoulders.
Speed limits are 35 to 45 miles an hour.
And what I'm asking to do is just simply a footnote, and for some that didn't get it, I would direct the Department of Transportation to report annually to the Long Range Capital Planning and Utilization Committee the following data for Route 153 from the Wakefield Town Line to Eaton Conway Line.
Traffic counts by town with an average speed, road conditions to include shoulders, accident data is by location, and correspondences to the department from towns and citizens with safety concerns in this corridor.
One of the major safety concerns that keep coming through is the school buses don't have adequate place to stop and traffic running up on them.
So I have been also not only with the traffic bureau with executive counselor Kenny the other selectmen I mentioned I'm sorry I've got something in my mouth here to form we will form on our own a town committee to discuss these issues and then work with the Planning Commission for the next round of the 10-year plan.
So it's simply a footnote to be put into DOT.
I discussed it briefly with the Commissioner earlier and did not seem to have resistance, and I'm happy to answer any questions.
This is an annual requirement?
Yes, sir.
Any questions of Representative McConkie on this proposal?
Representative Ebel.
So thank you for bringing this forward, Representative.
I'm familiar with that route.
is there a cost associated with any of this except for maybe the traffic counts or most of it they might be doing anyway right yes thank you representative evil the most of it is being collected and I will coordinate with the planning commission in the area on the traffic counts and so forth.
We're just trying to get it into a central database and let the towns bring it forward.
Yeah, we are.
You've heard Representative McConkie's proposal for an addition to the committee amendment on House Bill 2022.
Is there any, what is the will of the committee?
Representative Eaton moves, Representative McConkie seconds.
This is a straw poll because it will have to go into the committee amendment.
Does the commissioner have anything to say about it?
Thank you.
We always check because you've got to do the work.
Like I said, this is a straw poll.
It will be incorporated into a committee amendment.
All those in favor of incorporating what Representative McConkie is proposing signify by saying aye.
Aye.
Opposed nay.
The ayes have it, and it will go into the committee amendment.
Second item I'd like to bring up, which is Golf Links Road.
What is the pleasure of the committee on that issue, since we've had long discussion and public comment on it?
Representative McConkie.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I understand the need, but Thank you.
Representative McConkie.
Funding which might be possible for this project Thank you is there are there any other comments or is there another motion?
It wasn't a motion.
It was a statement of fact that he does not support it and unless somebody brings forward a positive motion It will not be included Is there a positive motion?
Seeing none, thank you all.
Now I think we probably do need to have the commissioner be able to answer some questions on the next couple.
We heard earlier this today from the representative from Stratum, as well as the planning agent for the town of Stratum about trying to do something with two projects that are in the 10-year plan to do anything with that proposal at this time.
Seeing none, it will not be brought up.
Unless, no, I'm not even going to ask you.
It's a policy decision.
Did you look at trying to do any of that?
It is last minute, and it might be better to wait until the Senate has it so that you can actually do all the number crunching on changing projects and moving money around.
So we talked about it during the recess, and the information that Bill Cass had shared is accurate.
These two projects were initiated through different avenues.
The project that's slated to go to construction in 2023 is a minor improvement that does not require significant right-of-way or environmental permitting and is associated with a resurfacing contract so it's very different scope that's why we're able to do that work next year we did take a look at the timing of the funding for the project that they would like to accelerate and as bill said you, we can't commit to doing things sooner based on our current schedule and our current understanding of the scope.
But certainly if we can get through the design and permitting process more quickly, we would look to move that project into construction when it's ready, not necessarily when the funding is currently programmed in the 10-year plan.
So we have made the commitment to advance that project as fast as we can, given the safety concerns at that location, but the permitting will dictate the schedule.
Thank you, Commissioner.
And just for everybody who may be listening over the live stream, the Commissioner does have quite a bit of latitude funding dependent on moving projects up as permitting and other things happen.
So this is not an unusual situation for the department to be in.
Yes, I think for the benefit of the new members, we've talked about this briefly, but every year we have opportunities to access additional federal funds through a process called redistribution.
We honor the priorities in the 10-year plan.
So based on readiness, we then evaluate which projects we have that could utilize those additional federal dollars.
Of course, we have to look at the different categories of funding.
So we still use the 10-year plan and this process to set the priority, but whatever is ready, we do try to accelerate should we receive additional federal funds.
Thank you.
Unless somebody from the committee has a different approach and wants to make a motion, the projects as outlined in the current draft 10-year plan will stay the same.
Is there any motion on the part?
Seeing none, they will stay as they are in the draft.
Now to the harder one.
Hudson.
So as I shared this morning, we've been taking a really close look at fiscal year 23.
And while we have a constrained 10-year plan, of course, we have a certain amount of contingency associated with each project, but the projects slated to be advanced in 23 are much more further along in terms of design.
That's why they're good candidates to advance in that time frame.
And we are very subscribed when it comes to the 23 year.
So what we currently have as a recommendation is to make $250,000 available in fiscal year 24 and then $750,000 available in fiscal year 25 to complete the feasibility study.
The estimated cost was $1 million.
So that's what we've found so far.
We'll keep looking and maybe in the Senate phase be able to move things up sooner.
But should the committee want to entertain this request, we do believe that we can make some funding available in those two years.
But we still caveat that we're seeing costs go up, an escalation on our projects.
So we are tapping into some of that contingency that we'd set aside.
But that's currently what we think we could accommodate.
And I think that we briefly talked about language on what the feasibility study would be to include in here along with funding by year.
Were you able to get that done?
Yes, we have a suggested amendment that we can pass out for the committee's .
If you would, please.
And we'll take a minute for the committee to look at it before we take action on it.
If any.
Thank you.
Representative McConkie and the chair recognizes Representative Mills Thank you Mr.
Chair I only had a question for the DOT as to what programs are called non-par we're not familiar with that one and we saw in an old 10 year plan this project listed as an individual and it had been funded with non-par funds.
So non-par is an abbreviation for non-participating.
So I had, I believe, shared this morning when this project was introduced into the 10-year plan originally, there was no federal Turnpike or state funds allocated to the project.
At that time, it was anticipated that the town would pursue the bill grant that was referenced this morning during the public hearing.
And so when the project was added to the 10-year plan, it was purely to give the department the authorization to work with Hudson, review their design submittals, and give them feedback.
We would not have been managing the project.
So that's why the suggested language for this feasibility study is to reintroduce the project but also amend the scope to reflect that the Department is now conducting the feasibility study and that we are going to be using federal funds.
Thank you.
Any other questions or discussion on the motion to include the Hudson Project in the committee amendment?
I'll see you soon.
Any other questions or discussion on the motion to include the Hudson project in the committee amendment?
Representative Eaton.
In the feasibility study, would that also include the possibility of having this project be included in the turnpike system?
At this point, we're not contemplating evaluating the full circumferential highway.
This would be to include only the Hudson Boulevard in the 10-year plan, which would not be Turnpike funded.
This would be federally funded.
Thank you.
Any other comments or questions?
Seeing none, again, this is a straw poll on whether or not to include the proposed amendment on the Hudson Project into the committee amendment on House Bill 2022.
All those in favor signify by saying aye.
Aye.
Opposed, nay.
The ayes have it and it will be included.
Commissioner, I believe you had another amendment that you were going to bring forward about municipal bridges?
Yes.
Or how do you want to handle it?
Yes, we can pass out the amendment for the bridges next.
I did that because it's in front of me.
That's right.
So where to begin?
As you recall, the bipartisan infrastructure law or the iija was passed um towards the end of the gasset phase and so while we tried to program all of the additional dollars that were going to be made available we did not yet have rules and guidelines concerning all of the programs.
And so we made our best guess in terms of which existing projects that were part of the State Aid Bridge Program, which is a state-funded program, would be eligible to accelerate with these additional federal dollars.
A couple of weeks ago, the Federal Highway Administration issued formal guidance for the new bridge program.
We've been reviewing all of the projects that were selected.
Before you is some language to specify of the existing projects enrolled in the State bridge program which ones we would anticipate moving from the State Aid Bridge Program into this new, what we call mobile.
It's a municipally owned bridge program funded specifically with the new bridge money.
So we're receiving $225 million over five years, essentially $45 million per year, dedicated to bridges, and 15% of that is to be used for municipally owned bridges.
And so that's what we're doing.
We went through all of the state aid bridge projects.
Now, one of the important things that you should be aware of is in New Hampshire, we define a bridge as anything with a span greater than 10 feet, but the federal definition is bridges with a span greater than 20 feet so there are many projects in the state a bridge program that yes they're municipally owned but they don't meet the federal definition of a bridge and so we've gone through carefully and made sure that we've identified which project belongs and so that's what's before you.
Questions from members of the committee about the changes in funding of municipal bridges and the years that it is anticipated that the projects will be done.
You'll note that they are all relatively soon because the additional money runs out in five years, if I'm correct.
We get five years' worth of funding.
The last year's funding does not expire in that year.
We have three years to spend it.
But yes, our goal is to accelerate projects that were already in the State A Bridge Program.
So while we have a longer...!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
just where you notice that they are all relatively soon.
That is a reflection of the advancement of the projects.
That was one of the goals through the Gasset process.
And this list reflects just a more detailed, appropriate funding that we didn't have the time to do at the end of the Gasset process.
Thank you.
Any questions on this?
Representative Thompson.
Can you define municipal bridge for me?
I mean, you said the span, but I can think of one in particular in my town that has needed replacement for many years.
The town finally voted to do that, hired a designer, an engineering firm, and it came up so expensive the town couldn't afford to do it.
And I think at the time it was declared that buses shouldn't travel over the road, but they have no option they still do I'm wondering if that's so the state a bridge program was a state funded program it was really first come first serve and so over the years the department has worked with communities, identified projects.
A couple of years ago now, we went through all of the existing projects that were in the State Aid Bridge Program.
We more thoroughly looked at the scope and the estimates for those projects.
And as a result, we realized that we were actually slightly oversubscribed.
We adjusted the timing of those projects to more accurately reflect when we could deliver them.
But basically, we were fully subscribed out through 2028, 2027?
28.
This opportunity we now have with the additional federal funds will allow us to accelerate a lot of those projects.
And so what we anticipate doing is two years from now, when we're doing the next 10-year plan update, we'll do a solicitation.
And with the additional dollars that have been freed up by using federal funds, we'll start to program other bridges that we can tackle in those out years with the additional capacity that we'll now have.
What we've been talking about through the Executive Council phase and the Gasset phase is changing how we conduct that solicitation to make it more equitable.
Like I said, the old program was first come, first served.
We have some communities who happen to be, based on geography, bridge rich.
They have a disproportionate number of bridges for the size of their population, so we're going to try and come up with a criteria that allows us to administer this program in a more equitable fashion.
But we need a little bit of time to do that, So the goal would be to work on that criteria, consult with the regional planning commissions and with the legislature, and then we'll program more bridge projects two years from now.
And to be honest, with this additional federal funding, we're going to be really working hard with the municipalities to accelerate all of this work.
But it will clear the deck, so to speak, of all the legacy projects and allow us to start working with communities who have needs that we couldn't meet with the existing state revenues.
Follow up, Mr.
Chairman.
So how do we get on the list?
Well, that will be the thing.
So any bridge over 10 feet would be eligible for the state- program.
For off system federal funds, it's any bridge over 20 feet and we will be developing a solicitation.
So probably two years from now or 18 months from now approximately that you'd have an opportunity to submit your candidate projects.
But that would be for funding probably beyond 2026.
Thank you very much.
Representative Edgar.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Commissioner.
On the 19th of January, you handed out a great handout, and it showed us the IIJA funding categories.
And for the bridges, you show like $225 million there, and then you later on have a list of what you're going to apply it to.
Is there more monies than the $225 now?
Because obviously the list you just handed out is great, and it shows probably twice as many as you had on the list that you handed out with the handout on the 19th.
So did the amount of money expand?
The amount of money did not increase.
We've just done a deeper dive into each project and made sure that it's eligible for the different categories.
So this document more fully explains which projects are staying in the State Abridge Program, which projects are moving into the new what we call mobile program.
In other words, they're funded by the bipartisan infrastructure law bridge money, that $225 million.
And then we have some projects that were always going to be federally funded, which would be funded through what's called the Mo Bridge Program, which is from our from our core federal formula funds, we have a municipally owned bridge rehab and replacement program.
So we have old state aid bridge, state funds.
We have formula bridge money, which is Mo Bridge.
And then we have the new infrastructure law one time money, which is mobile.
And so to make sure that you all fully understood which bridge was going to be in which program, we're providing this more comprehensive list.
That's great.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
Representative Eaton.
Just please feel free to correct me if I'm wrong.
My understanding is when municipalities want the bridge aid, they go out and they do the bridge design.
And I think some can get Thank you.
Feel free to correct me if I'm wrong.
My understanding is when municipalities want the bridge aid, they go out and they do the bridge design.
And I think some can get more extravagant than others.
Is there any way for DOT to rein in what a cost or design might be versus getting something that's precast or a box culvert for a small bridge or a 20-footer?
Or can they pretty much do whatever they want?
I'm just thinking, are there ways to get economies of scale for this to go further?
So one of our concerns is that when we convert some of these projects from state funded to federal funds, the cost of the project will actually go up because we have to meet all of the federal requirements.
Now, we're not placing any additional burden on the municipality from a financial perspective because the infrastructure law allows us to allocate 100% federal funds.
So these communities who were enrolled in the State A Bridge Program, they would have been following state standards, but they would have been responsible for a 20% cash match to the state funds.
If we're enrolling a project now in the federal program, following the federal requirements means more construction inspection and some higher overhead costs but the benefit is they'll have zero match to provide.
It'll be 100% federal.
Thank you.
And if I may, we are involved in all of these.
Typically, the initial estimate is when somebody enrolls in the State Aid Bridge Program, it would have been vetted by our bridge design to prevent some of the either low-balling or inaccurate costs.
It's still a very conceptual project and then then the municipalities manage it from them they hire an engineer and they develop the concepts and stuff but every step of the way it is reviewed by department staff.
And usually it ends up, it's not extravagant things that the town is looking to do, because they do have a 20% match.
It's usually environmental type of things that a bridge ends up getting longer than the bridge it's replacing for new requirements and things like that so representative evil i'm just trying to check my math here so if you have 225 million over five years 45 million per year 15 for municipal bridges so are you saying that we have about seven million million in federal funds annually we can use for municipal bridges?
Correct.
So basically we've doubled the size of the State Aid Bridge Program.
Projects that were enrolled in the State Aid Bridge Program we received through SB367 $6.8 million annually.
and our 15% of the 45 million means we're essentially doubling the State Aid Bridge Program.
But that's not the only municipal bridges that we're doing.
There are municipally owned bridges that are part of the national highway system, so we're also doing some of those projects, but they weren't in the State Aid Bridge Program.
They were being funded with federal funds because they're eligible.
So we are spending more than the 14 million on municipally owned bridges.
But essentially when it comes to the off system bridges, the ones that aren't considered part of the national highway system, we've essentially doubled our capacity with the federal funds and the state funds.
Great, Thank you.
Representative McConkie moves that the proposed amendment on municipal-owned bridges and how it's being funded and be incorporated into the committee amendment on House Bill 2022.
Representative Eaton seconds.
Is there any further discussion?
Thank you.
and be incorporated into the committee amendment on House Bill 2022.
Representative Eaton seconds.
Is there any further discussion?
Seeing none, all those in favor signify by saying aye.
Aye.
Opposed, nay.
It will be incorporated.
That was all I had.
I know you were going to look at a couple other things, Commissioner.
So we have one more amendment that I'd like to spend some time going through.
Our apologies.
We brought forward an amendment, some suggested language at the last work session.
And as we've talked specifically about the circumferential in Hudson Boulevard, and we have some thoughts on perhaps a cleaner way to address potential conflicts that exist in the statutes today as it pertains to the Turnpike system.
We are currently reaching out to LBA for their endorsement of what we're doing, but we wanted to walk the committee through a suggested amendment.
and so as Kathy's passing that out I'll give you a little bit of history so RSA 237 pertains to the Turnpike system and of course the Turnpike system predates the 10-year plan process certain sections within the statute were first introduced back in the early 70s and our 10-year plan process was implemented when governor sununu was in office in the 80s and so the department over the years has strived to make sure that the respective sections of the turnpike statute align with what's in the 10-year plan but we've come to realize that there's certain authorities that we were granted in the past that don't reflect the current projects in the 10-year plan and also certain sections of the statute were established when we were building the turnpike system it was initially being created we're not in the business of building significant portions of New Road anymore.
We're maybe modifying the limits of the Turnpike or adding smaller sections.
And so we don't see the need for additional language.
Really, the process that we follow through RSA 240, the 10-year plan, it adequately governs the spending of federal and state funds.
So we believe that it would be appropriate to repeal certain sections of the statute now and just reference RSA 240.
Because in reality, that's the process that we follow today.
So before you, we have some suggestions on language to strike so rsa 237 colon 2 articulates the authorities granted to the department to construct projects and you'll notice that a lot of the projects listed here are those to originally construct sections of the turnpike projects that were completed many many years ago so instead of having reference to old legacy projects we think it's appropriate going forward to purely reference the project that we intend to construct in the future and all of those articulated in the 10-year plan so for as an example things that are really redundant and should have been struck a while ago, in 237 colon 2 Roman numeral 2a, it talks about a study that was to be conducted to construct a four-lane east-west highway from 393 all the way to the Spalding Turnpike of course that project was evaluated at one point in time but it was never deemed feasible so there's a lot of redundant language in here whether it's projects that were built many years ago or projects that were just not advanced or move forward so we're suggesting that we essentially strike that entire section keeping basically the opening sentences that the commissioner with the approval of governor and council is authorized to and we are skipping all the way to what was old roman numeral nine to make other and further improvements to the turnpike system as may be required by rsa 240 which is the tenure plan otherwise we're trying to constantly update this language to match the 10-year plan bill so that would be something that would be helpful from a housekeeping perspective and then associated with that we'd want to repeal 237 colon 7.
so the way the statutes are structured colon 2 articulates the projects in section 7 it articulates the funding for each project.
So it's actually separated, which makes it harder to track as well.
Because you'll notice in this section of the statute, you sometimes have a Roman numeral than ABC and a breakout of projects.
Whereas in section seven, all the funding is in one allocation.
So last time when we had met with the committee we suggested some language to increase our authorities in 237 colon 7 to match with the current 10 year plan.
We're now thinking that that was perhaps the wrong approach.
We perhaps should just repeal all of 237 colon 7 because all the money is programmed in the 10 year plan through RSASA 240.
So we're going to make sure we get LBA's concurrence, but this will ensure there's never any conflict between what's programmed through the 10-year plan process and what's in other sections of the statute.
And actually, there is a conflict today.
So one of the items that was introduced in this 10-year plan was to do a feasibility study for exit 10 on the spalding turnpike if you go to 237 colon 2 roman numeral 2b it says that we're authorized to make improvements to the Spalding Turnpike by constructing exit 10, which is not what's clearly in the 10-year plan.
So that's why we'd like to avoid this potential issue by just eliminating this whole section.
Like I said, we don't have any additional requirements in statute for federal or state funds, so we'd just be saying that we're going to allocate funding to projects on the Turnpike the same way that we do for the rest of the highway system and follow RSA 240.
So if we were to adopt this as part of House Bill 2022, what we had originally from you about the turnpike system funds provided would be stricken from any amendment, and we would just go with a complete rewrite of 237.2 is essentially what we're looking at, and repeal of 237.7.
Questions or comments from members of the committee?
Representative Eaton.
Just a quick thank you.
I've advocated for 20 years, particularly to new legislators, that when you come in and you go to introduce a bill, you should have an equal obligation to find language that is obsolete and put in a bill to repeal.
So it's nice to see somebody trying to clean up the books.
Any other?
Representative Jack.
any other representative jack thank you so so i understand that in the in the committee amendment that was passed out we would now if we adopt this we delete all of section four so the motion would be to to adopt the what the commissioner just passed out and remove Section 4 from the committee amendment.
And I'll make that motion.
It's been moved by Representative Jack to amend the committee report by striking what we have currently in front of us on Turnpike System number four and insert the amended language on RSA.
What we have currently in front of us on Turnpike System No.
4 and insert the amended language on RSA 237 on authority granted to the Commission and the repeal of RSA 237.
Seven funds provided.
Is there a second?
Representative Abbott seconds.
Any questions or discussion?
This is a big change to the RSAs.
I personally think it's good at this point to clean things up because I've always got confused by why are we continuing just to update dollar amounts in the 10-year plan for the turnpike.
I mean, I knew why, but it was, why don't we do something about it?
And I thank the commissioner for bringing this forward.
Anybody else?
Any further comments?
Again, it's a straw poll to accept the proposed amendment to House Bill 2022 as moved by Representative Jack that under our current committee amendment, we would strike Section 4 and insert the proposed amendment provided to us by the committee, I mean by the commissioner on RSA 237-2 and 237-7.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor of inserting that into the committee amendment signify by saying aye.
Aye.
Opposed nay.
The ayes have it and it will be included.
Commissioner, that was all, I believe.
Thank you.
Can I ask one thing that just came to me about the bridge reallocation that we did earlier?
This means that towns that happen to be in the time window to take advantage of the federal funds would be excused from their local match requirement under state aid bridge.
So in some sense, it's a matter of timing that they're getting that windfall.
Yes, we've had to go through and look carefully at how far projects were in the design to make sure that we could convert them to federal funds.
In the federal program, you can't expend dollars until you have federal approvals.
So there were some projects that were too far along that we couldn't federalize them even though they were eligible.
And so this really reflects which projects based on both eligibility and the phase of design could be incorporated to the program.
All right.
Just so everybody is aware of what we have agreed to.
Last time we were here in our work session, we agreed to changes to two projects on the FE Everett Turnpike, an ownership transfer of Continental Boulevard and the location of the main line toll and plaza in Bedford.
Today we have adopted for inclusion into the committee amendment, the amendments to RSA 237-2 and 237-7.
We have also adopted to include in the committee amendment all of the information on municipal bridge projects and how they'll be funded.
We have also included funding for a project in Hudson for a feasibility study and a proposal for the department to provide some information on an annual basis about traffic on St.
Road 153.
That is what I have.
That is what will go to legislative services for incorporation into a committee amendment, which we will not stick around today to vote on.
We have a continued executive session on this.
It will take legislative services a bit of time to put this all together and make sure it's right.
We will vote on that on the 24th of February.
Representative McConkie, you had a quick...
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
A general question for the commissioner, if if i could um i've been haunted ever since you spoke and said you had difficulty getting out of your driveway with a snowstorm i i uh my sons can't believe the commissioner couldn't do that so planning but my question is uh yeah spring spring always sneaks up on me and what happens with our roads and potholes.
Last week, up north, 16 and other roads just started peeling away.
And you've probably already addressed this in a previous conversation with the committee.
Are our funds on track with those annual repairs that we have to do to get those roads back in place, stitched together?
So we really have five seasons in New Hampshire.
We have the four official seasons and then pothole season, depending how uh the free style cycle goes throughout the winter months um so yes you know our maintenance forces will be out uh patching potholes and trying to hold things together until the summer construction season um as usual we'll have our district resurfacing program that will make improvements and then we have a certain amount of betterment funding that we make available for the districts to do greater shim and paver shim on roadways that aren't scheduled for paving that year but we have some concerns around you know how that road's going to hold out through another winter season until we do an assessment sort of the end of the winter it's hard to project if we have all the funding that we need, but certainly we'll be working to make sure that we address the sections that are in very poor condition.
Thank you, Commissioner.
Representative Ebel.
Thank you.
Unrelated to Representative McConkie's question, I thought the department was going to give us an aggregate number of the amount of money in tolls that had been lost because of the toll booth removals in Merrimack and also the costs associated with removal of the infrastructure.
I apologize, Representative.
We did pull that information together and we have it with us.
We did not pass it out given the nature of today's meeting.
It's not a work session.
So thank you for bringing that to our attention.
I'm going to let Bill Cass walk you through the numbers because he and our Turnpike folks are the ones that have testified each time there was legislation concerning removing the toll plazas.
Thank you.
I wanted to make sure I presented it because there's a couple of different numbers because we're kind of comparing pre-COVID and post-COVID.
The numbers that I have are presented at the time that the tolls were removed.
So the revenue loss at the removal of exit 12 and 11, which was pre-COVID, was around $1.4 million.
Exit 10, which was just removed this January 1st, was post-COVID.
And the revenue from that was around $300,000.
So a total is $1.7 million in annual revenue because of the elimination of those tolls.
And I think, Representative Graham, you had asked also about some of the other incidental costs.
So that's just a loss of revenue.
It's cost around roughly $2 million, $1.9 million for the physical removal of all three of those tolls between $600,000 and $800,000 at each one of those three plazas.
And then the final removal of the tunnel and the demolition and the removal of the buildings and the excess pavement and reconfiguring the ramps, which will be done under the overall Turnpike Widening Project, is about $4 million.
So you would ask for those three kind of components and revenue loss, what the immediate removal of the tolls were, and then the full remediation of completely removing the infrastructure.
Thank you.
Any further questions, comments?
Representative?
Excuse me?
I will give a little bit of latitude to since the commissioner is here and seems to be willing to answer some questions which she always is but we have finished with what we are going to be doing today on House Bill 2022.
But if she is willing to entertain one or two brief and cogent questions, go ahead.
Thank you, Commissioner.
This is my 10-year gripe of are we making any greater progress on cutbacks on scenic vistas on the interstate highway system that, as you know, when it was designed, was designed for scenic vistas that have all grown in, which also create icing hazards on the highway.
And I had tried to manage a cooperative between what used to be DREAD and you guys, and it all came down to who was going to get the money and where the Fed's going to do it and who was going to get paid.
Is there anything I can get from you for language, anything that we can do to help to bring back the scenic vistas on the highway system, get cutbacks done and improve icing conditions etc so representative we have made some efforts to cut back within the right-of-way that we own around the scenic vistas of course with covid and our reduced revenues we've had to prioritize our work so we haven't necessarily kept up in the last couple of years the way that we'd hoped the real issue at number of the scenic vistas is that we don't own the land where the trees have grown up it's private property in front of the state right of way and between the view and the roadway and so it really would be an extensive effort to try and partner with those abutters and neighbors to see if they're willing to do some selective clearing on their property to restore the view.
Especially in the lakes region areas, that's very much the case.
We own a limited right-of-way and then trees have grown up between the roadway and the lake and so that's what's obstructing the view and we don't have the authority to go in and clear trees on somebody else's property.
So we were willing to partner with DRED at the time, but every location that we went to, we cleared as much as we could, but it was really beyond the state-owned right-of-way where we had the issues blocking the view.
Anything else?
Here's Representative Newin.
Yes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I hope this qualifies in kind of a catch-all for a question to the Commissioner.
Yes, Commissioner, probably a couple of years ago anyway, talked about wintertime, our snowplows, and some difficulty in attracting and maintaining your snowplow drivers.
It was financial.
It was a quality of life issue and whatever.
How is it this year?
Thank you.
So like every employer in the state, we are really struggling to recruit and retain talent.
And our vacancy rate, yes, is higher than it has been in the past.
We are very, very fortunate that we have a number of individuals across the department who have a commercial driver's license, a CDL, and they've been willing to volunteer and supplement our highway maintainers who perform winter maintenance.
So we have been working very hard to ensure that for every storm we have a person in every truck but we have no real bench anymore and if it wasn't for those volunteers we certainly would have a very different performance but that's what's great about being the commissioner for DOT it's an all hands on deck approach to things and we have individuals who are always willing to step up.
So it's not easy, and certainly if we have a prolonged winter, we do get concerned about burnout.
We don't have multiple shifts.
These guys work around the clock to keep the roads clear and only take safety breaks when they work for multiple days.
So we really express our gratitude not only to our DOT employees within highway maintenance, but like I said, those from throughout operations and other bureaus who do their part, as well as the hire trucks, the contractors who work alongside us as well.
On which?
We're deleting it.
I know.
Commissioner, I was looking at an amendment which we've deleted, but it says construction of a second barrel.
The term doesn't register with me after all these years.
On the Spalding.
What is a barrel?
So a barrel is basically one half of a divided highway.
So we talk about the northbound and the southbound barrels of the interstate as an example or the Spalding.
Okay.
So thank you.
And one second or so I am going to recess the executive session on House Bill 2022.
We will take it back up again on February 24th with a committee amendment.
Hopefully, we will have it all.
Everything that we agreed to will be in it and that we can all support it at that point and finish up.
And that morning we also have two other bills that we have to held an executive session on and whatever other work may come before the committee at that time.
Any questions on the work plan?
All right.
Okay.
Now, more of a procedural question.
This amendment we're working on, when do you think it will be ready?
By the 24th.
Because the reason I asked this, if it could be emailed in advance, we could look it over and make sure everything's okay and hopefully exec the amendment and the bill within a few minutes when we meet again the 24th.
I will see how long it takes between committee, the other work that they're working on for other committees as well, as well as two days of session.
We'll see.
It's a great idea though okay thank you any other comments if not the executive session on House Bill 2022 is in recess until February 24th.
And again, Commissioner, to you and your staff, appreciate the work and the quick turnaround that goes into it.
And watch out that some of the mics are live, people.
Thank you.